5 25 on your wednesday morning viewers  chiming in on this giant video screen by  busy roads remember the other day viewer  terry was asking what could possibly go  wrong with a 27 600 square foot video  screen on the side of a legion stadium  for folks to watch football while the  driving by on the freeway well gloria  chimed in distracting drivers with giant  screens is stupid stupid stupid  isn't it bad enough they refused to put  down their phones amen gloria julia  chimes in it's ridiculous to distract  drivers more than they already are with  navigation screens phones in one hand a  burger in the other we're smarter than  that vegas  save lives don't be foolish enough to  put big tvs next to our roadway what's  next roadside video games you can  hotspot into  wow buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone something's driving you  crazy the email address traffic eight at  8newsnow.com